VINAYAK LOHANI: Thanks
so much for coming here
and for giving an opportunity
to do be here at Google.
What we'll do is that
we'll start with a video
because that's
very visual, and I
think lots of things-- it will
give an idea about our work.
And after that, I'll run
through a quick presentation,
and then we can have a Q&A. So
I'll just start with this film.
NARRATOR: Kolkata-- a
densely populated metropolis
on the banks of the Ganges,
sustaining the livelihood
of millions, a city that
has blended modernization
with glorious history,
life on the move,
a city with a global outlook.
The other face of globalized
Kolkata-- a grim truth
mired in poverty, helplessness,
and abhorrent living
conditions.
Lives filled with misery
without any hope for salvation.
FEMALE SPEAKER:
[NON ENGLISH SPEECH].
[NON ENGLISH SPEECH]
FEMALE SPEAKER:
[FEMALE SPEAKER:
[NON ENGLISH SPEECH]
FEMALE SPEAKER:
-Within these dark
lanes of Kolkata,
a man searching for
the truth of life,
listening to his inner voice,
a man thinking beyond himself,
wanting to help deprived human
beings rejected by the society,
having a vision for providing
them a grand, big family.
FEMALE SPEAKER:
[NON ENGLISH SPEECH]
MALE SPEAKER:
FEMALE SPEAKER:
[NON ENGLISH SPEECH]
-This man has been
looking after hundreds
of children from
deprived families
by giving them quality education
and inculcating in them
high moral values.
VINAYAK LOHANI: One
day it struck me
that I should start a shelter
home for children, children
from very difficult
backgrounds, and to whom
I could dedicate my whole life.
I could bring them up as my own
younger brothers and younger
sisters.
So in that spirit, as
a guardian to them,
I can live my whole life.
When I decided to
start the shelter home,
I was first looking for land
where I could start and then do
some construction in that land.
But even a small
piece of land was
costing so much that it was just
beyond any kind of imagination
that I had.
So I decided to start
in a rented building.
I therefore saw a few
buildings and finally zeroed
on a rented building,
which was nearby
on campus and rent of which
was around 12,000 rupees.
So I started taking lectures
for [? NBS ?] parents
and some coaching and
students in Kolkata.
And through that, I
could meet this rent.
NARRATOR: The financial
position of Parivaar
started improving as
it gained popularity
within his family,
friends, and colleagues.
His mother, an ardent believer
in the goodness of people,
was the first donor of Parivaar.
Within a year, Vinayak
had enough funds
to buy two acres of land at 24
Parganas and to start Parivaar.
VINAYAK LOHANI: So in
this way I started.
The first three
children I brought
from a village
around 20 kilometers
from Kolkata from extremely
deprived backgrounds.
And with that, after 15 days,
another 10 children came.
So at the end of
say, two months,
I had around 30
children already.
I then began to write
email appeals-- first
to IIM, Kolkata [INAUDIBLE]
because [INAUDIBLE] I
had access to.
Though I had written to
more than 1,000 people,
percentage-wise a very
small percentage responded.
But still, number-wise it
was around 20, 25 people who
responded, which was
very encouraging to me
because I realized that when I'm
just starting this work, even
at this stage there are people
who are showing confidence
in me, showing trust in me.
NARRATOR: As the number
of children grew,
Vinayak realized that Parivaar
should have its own school
to cater to the unique need
of and ideal development
of the children at Parivaar.
Amar Bharat Vidyapeeth is
affiliated to the West Bengal
Board of Education
and runs classes
till the high-school level.
This ensures that the children
have a recognized certificate
to continue higher education on
the way to their career paths.
The Vidyapeeth
teaches the children
to be proficient in three
languages-- Bengali, English,
and Hindi.
VINAYAK LOHANI: So
all our children
till grade 10 studied here.
And in grade 11, 12, and for
graduation-- in colleges--
They attend some
outside institutions,
which have the stream
they want to study.
NARRATOR: Every
child at Parivaar
is able to aspire
for a brighter future
based on the quality education
and life skills they receive
at Parivaar.
The initial focus on children
from urban and rural areas
was expanded to include
children of highly impoverished
tribal areas, where even two
square meals were not available
and malnutrition was rampant.
RAMESH BIHOR:
[NON ENGLISH SPEECH].
VINAYAK LOHANI: At
Parivaar, we have
residential children
from around 14,
15 different districts, around
12 districts in West Bengal,
two districts in Jharkhand,
and a few pockets in Bihar
and Chhattisgarh also.
NARRATOR: Every year, Parivaar
screens more than 1,500 cases
of needy children for admission.
These children are in
the age group of 5 to 10.
Parivaar has a detailed
pre-admission screening
process, which
includes a site visit
to determine that the child is
extremely needy and vulnerable
and in need of long-term
residential support.
One of the criteria
in selecting the child
is to determine that there
is a minimal possibility
of a dropout of the
child from Parivaar.
VINAYAK LOHANI: We
ensure that we are not
looking for a short-term
stay at Parivaar--
just for, say, a
couple of years or so--
but for a long-term
transformation.
So if a child is admitted
at the age of five,
our aim is start their
higher education, which
could be graduation and
after that, a job placement.
Until that level, the
child will be at Parivaar.
NARRATOR: Most NGO and
government-run shelters
support the children until
they attain the age of 18.
The support is withdrawn
after the child turns 18.
Parivaar has no such age limit.
VINAYAK LOHANI: I think that
just like in a family how
a family supports a child to
the last possible conclusion,
it could be higher education.
It could be job
placement, depending
on the potential of
that child, giving
all kinds of
opportunities to make
the most of their potential.
So this was my vision,
that just like a family,
Parivaar will also hand-hold the
child until the last conclusive
stage, which does full justice
to his or her potential.
NARRATOR: Parivaar is now
West Bengal's largest free
residential institution,
a home to more than 1,000
less-privileged children
served by a team of deeply
committed, 170-plus
full-time staff.
Parivaar has two
campuses furnished
with dorm-like
housing, a school which
has its own library,
computer lab, dining
halls, medical rooms, recreation
halls, playfields, etc.
Here, every child is
seen as a project.
And there is a high
degree of adherence
to an individualized plan
of action for each child.
Most children, when
admitted into Parivaar,
are without any exposure
to letters on numerals.
Parivaar has devised a
structured bridging program
for children between
the ages of 5 and 10,
whereby these
children are provided
tutoring for 6 to 12 months to
bring their education levels
at par with their age group.
VINAYAK LOHANI: I think
this is very important
because this correction has to
be done in the initial phase
itself.
At the age of 15, nobody would
want to sit in grade six.
So the backlog has to be
minimized at the starting point
itself so that when
they are 10 or 11
they are actually in
grades 4, or 5, or 6.
After the bridging,
the children are
admitted into our own in-campus
school Amar Bharat Vidyapeeth.
NARRATOR: After school
hours, special tutors
help the children in enhancing
their academic performances.
Children who had no
opportunity of going to school,
whose nutrition,
safety, and well-being
were also under question, now
start aspiring to be teachers,
to be engineers, to be
doctors, and to enter
many such other careers.
A high happiness quotient
maintained in the family
is the reason for the negligible
dropout rate at Parivaar.
The atmosphere around Parivaar
lends itself to self esteem
and creates hope amongst
the resident children.
100% of the children of Parivaar
appearing for the board exam
clear the exam
with decent scores.
VINAYAK LOHANI: The emotional
and psychological nurturing
of each child, I think that
that is of a very high level.
And that, I believe, is the
most important achievement
of Parivaar.
Now, second is that
the aspiration level
of the children completely
changes, because their esteem
need here is really fulfilled.
The self-respect and the respect
from others that they get here
from our Seva
Bharatis, just like
in a family, how you are
sensitively dealt with.
NARRATOR: A full-time
staff member of Parivaar
is fondly referred
to as a Seva Bharati,
meaning the one who is
devoted to an ideal service.
The Seva Bharatis cater to all
the needs of the boys as well
as the girls.
SANDHYA NAG:
[NON ENGLISH SPEECH]
NARRATOR: The children from
the early batches of Parivaar
are now getting ready to
plunge into the competitive
professional world.
Some are working as interns in
industry and corporate offices,
while others are
strengthening their resumes
by gaining work experience.
Parivaar goes beyond
providing good education.
It also guides the children
in their choice of a career.
They are set on a
path on which they
would be able to create
a niche for themselves,
one conforming to the values
instilled during their stay
at Parivaar.
FIROZ: [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
NARRATOR: Every child has
a potential that needs
an opportunity for development.
If they are provided the
right kind of opportunity
and the right kind
of nurturing, they
have a tremendous
potential to do well.
NIMAI SAHA: [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
NARRATOR: Parivaar is
expanding like a juggernaut,
in popularity and in resources.
It is now the largest free
residential institution
in the state of West Bengal.
Vinayak is actively working on
expanding the current Parivaar
facility from accommodating
1,000 children
to 3,000 children.
PROF.
SOUGATA RAY: For the
last three or four years,
Vinayak had spent a lot of time
in building this kind of tier
of leadership.
And now we are very comfortable.
That's why that even
if Vinayak is not there
for several weeks in Parivaar,
Parivaar runs absolutely
smoothly, because the
next line of leadership
are perfectly in place.
NARRATOR: Inspired by the
teachings of selfless service
by Sri Rama Krishna,
Swami Vivekananda,
Vinayak Lohani is
helping transform
the lives of hundreds
of destitute children,
not only of West Bengal, but
also those from the surrounding
states like Jharkhand,
Bihar, and Chhattisgarh.
Parivaar, his vision, is
now a dream fulfilled.
This tireless journey of
determination and dedication
would provide a
role model for many.
VINAYAK LOHANI: So I'll
just spend 10 minutes
before we take questions on
like as the film also showed,
so basically,
Parivaar's emphasis
is on the overall
caretaking of children
from destitute backgrounds.
It's a non-denominational
organization,
so the only criteria is the high
neediness level of children.
And our core
inspiration has been
through the great spiritual
and humanistic teacher
in 19th century, the
Swami Vivekananda, whose
core theme was essential
divinity of man
and therefore service
to human beings
the highest form of
spiritual practice.
So when I just passed out of
IIM, at that time, [INAUDIBLE],
and I wanted to actually
live this kind of philosophy.
So at that time, also, one thing
was that, in social sector,
lots of things called
for a very high degree
of technical expertise.
They were domains like working
with farmers in downtrodden
areas , or environmental
issues, or many such things.
And I didn't have
any such thing.
So I asked myself,
then, what do I have?
I don't have any technical
expertise of such domains.
So I just thought that basic
human emotions, which are very,
very universal-- love and care.
So these basics [INAUDIBLE],
and I thought that,
let me start the work,
which is a manifestation
of these basic human values.
So my work did not start
with any cerebral motivation
or intellectual ideas.
There was no grand
idea involved.
I mean, I always say that
the most simple thing,
really speaking what
we have been doing.
Even an unlettered woman in
the most remote area in India
may be bringing up her children
with her utmost care and love.
So the idea was to manifest
these values, this sentiment.
So the whole organization
built on that spirit.
So all the processes which
happen at the organization
got built up.
They bore the stamp of
these guiding sentiments
of loving caring.
Now, so this is our mission--
changing lives permanently
of such children, homeless,
family-less children, highly
vulnerable children, so children
from backgrounds like orphans,
street children, girl children
from mass prostitution areas,
whose mothers are already--
They were victimized
at some point in time and
starting fresh in prostitution.
And they, themselves,
are very vulnerable
to being pushed into that
thing, because there's
a very high degree of
generation-to-generation
continuity in prostitution,
organized prostitution.
So these were our domains.
And then later on, from very
impoverished tribal areas,
particularly those
which were affected
by the Naxal movement of extreme
left-wing, violent movements.
There are pockets in
[INAUDIBLE] in eastern India.
So this was the thing.
So in three children just
in a rented building,
I did not have any funds.
I did not look for any kind of
funding support, formal funding
support.
I just started in my own way.
I did not have a job, because
I did not take up a job.
But some part-time,
I used to give
for just earning that
much, which could start,
which would help
me in starting this
and in this way, in a
rented building with friends
supporting, in that manner.
So actually, a huge degree
of individual support,
actually 75%, 80% of support
is through individuals.
And only I guess 20% through
institutional donors like, say,
corporates or funding
agencies, et cetera.
I always believed that
all the work in the world
is done by individuals.
So I always had a huge faith
in individual goodness.
Even institutional
support that we get
is as a result of championing
or some individual supporter
with internalized vision.
So that approach and
belief continues.
In this way, from tutoring
three all these years
are-- the residential
institution
has come up in this way.
And in next three
years, actually, we
are going for a
faster scaling now
that our processes are
all set, and leadership
at many different levels.
Operationally speaking,
Parivaar is now on an autopilot.
So even my involvement,
operationally speaking,
is not required to that extent.
So all other tiers of
leadership and management
have been created.
So we are looking for
a faster expansion
in the next few years, because
need for such a service
is huge in India.
Now, this is basically like
West Bengal and Jharkhand.
These are the primary bases
from where we have children.
We created our field networks
in these 14, 15 districts
and some other pockets in
neighboring states-- Bihar,
[INAUDIBLE], Chhattisgarh.
Statewise it's like this.
So immediate portion
is from West Bengal
and then some tribal
districts in Jharkhand,
impoverished districts.
Now, like the film
also mentioned,
so we screen a
large number of kids
which are brought to our
notice through diverse facets,
through field groups, local
NGOs, local self-government
like, say, panchayats,
or municipal authorities,
or government department of,
say, child welfare or police.
So all these, actually,
are primary referees
of cases and upon which
we do a very detailed site
visit and a neediness analysis
because our capacity of intake
at any point in time is limited.
And the cases which come to our
attention far outnumber that,
so it's really on the
basis of neediness.
And at the same
time, we also try
to assess that there are no
chance of dropout in that case.
So we just ensure during
our pre-admission exercise
and dialogue with the
referring party-- it could
be the relative or folks of
the village of the child--
that how desperate
and motivated they
are to see the child
into such a system
of long-term transformation.
So very often, I am
asked this question
of how do you motivate
the folks of the child,
and I answer it in this
way-- that we do not
have to motivate.
They have to motivate
us how desperately they
need such a service, because
another demand of such
is service is anyway huge.
And so neediness and,
at the same time,
minimal chance of
dropout from the program
these are our main
criteria while
short-listing for
admitting into Parivaar.
So children are admitted
during the age of 4 to 10.
That's the entry point.
And when, in case
of siblings, we
take all the siblings so that
the family bonding continues.
So you have a large
number of sets
of siblings, four brothers and
sisters, or three, like that.
So all of them,
together, progress.
And there is a
considerable degree
of rootedness with
their background,
like through our own field
visits to their areas,
or we invite
periodically [INAUDIBLE],
all the arrangements.
So from far-off places, 300,
400 miles, the relatives
or religious continue
to come to Parivaar.
So that ensures that
the children also
have the rootedness
with their earlier
community or background.
That remains intact.
So this also, I'm
very often asked,
that such a-- since there is
a very, very drastic shift,
so how do the children
themselves adjust to this?
But my experience has been
that they themselves take it
in a very, very positive way.
So rather than de-rooting
from their past,
it's actually an
enhanced motivation
to do-- conclude something,
give back, and actually impact
their own local
communities, once they
are in a position to do so.
So it's like this.
So education-wise,
also, younger children--
those who do not have a
backlog, who are, say,
like around five or six-- they
start with the earlier grades.
And those who are
slightly older, say,
8, 9, 10, almost
everyone at Parivaar
is without any
exposure to education.
So such children, who have a
huge backlog in terms of age,
they are taken through fast
learning bridging program
and then admitted to a
grade on par with their age.
So this is like our own school.
And after that, under
our care, only children
continue to-- like
just from a family,
how kids at an
outside institution.
So after, they are living.
Since teams become very
diverse, some kids actually
go for sciences,
some after that,
into engineering, computer.
We have kids in computer
science, engineering,
and, say, nursing, or it could
be other medical or some skill
in a vocational program.
We have a large-scale
vocational program also
for children who are
academically not that bright,
but that also ensures
a career, which
also has an upward
mobility possibility
through skilled programs.
In India these days, actually,
a huge amount of thing
is being done in the
skill space, which was not
the case a few years back.
That was a tremendous-- it
was a macro-level change,
and we are also getting benefit.
A few years back, I also
used to anxiety about this,
like about what about the
kids who are not doing well
academically or who have,
say, some kind of learning
disability or slow learners.
But a huge amount of vibrancy
is there in the last few years
at the national skill level
and corporation coming
and lots of courses in
blue collar space, which
ensures a sure placement and
placement in organized sector.
Earlier the skills space
was very disorganized.
It's becoming increasingly
more organized now.
So that's a good thing,
nationally speaking.
So these are also
supplementary-- we
have a lot of supplementary
support to education
so that children to do well,
just like how in a family
all the processes which
are there in a family
are in some form
replicated at our end.
So just like in a family, how
parents or older siblings would
guide, or tutor,
or mentor the kids,
we have our own
systems of doing that.
So it's basically right from,
you could say, KG to PG,
also secondary out
into [INAUDIBLE]
graduation handholding,
and through a placement.
And actually, even after that,
they need a lot of support.
Like our kids, earliest kids,
are now getting into jobs.
So suppose they are in a city.
They have got a job
in Kolkata city.
So we have to ensure
that we do this stay.
And initially maybe one
year, one and a half year,
all that kind of support.
Maybe they have to take
a rental condition.
They have to give a deposit
for that, and all that.
So it's just like
having-- until they
are completely on their own.
So it's like how a
family would support.
Parivaar is actually a family
in the garb of an institution.
So skills and vocational are
something which I talked about.
So a number of courses, say,
hardware, computer hardware,
networking, electronics,
consumer goods servicing,
beautician, BPO, hotel
manager and hospitality,
a number of huge area
of such skilled programs
we run in collaboration also
with some specialist agencies,
which are doing that and which
ensure a placement after that,
guaranteed placement.
Now, in all of this, this
is the most important aspect
of Parivaar, even more
important than the education,
because in a residential
center, but in a family,
as you can imagine, many
of you will be parents.
So the responsibility
of parenting
and the same
responsibility we have.
So on health issues,
on overall care-taking.
So we have [INAUDIBLE]
system and very personalized.
So lots of children, when
they come to Parivaar,
they have huge malnourishment,
and supplements
have to be given to them.
So it's very, very
individualized.
Individualized health
charts are there.
Medical files are
there for all children.
Visual medical
histories are there
right from the time
they enter Parivaar.
We have a medical staff,
resident medical staff,
comprising nurses, paramedical
staff, et cetera, ambulances,
and everything,
arrangements with hospitals,
tie-ups with hospitals,
group insurance
for the whole children, so
all those kinds of things.
These are developments things,
which the film also depicted.
So I think the like
the immediate success
point of Parivaar is,
actually, ensuring
that there is a
really high degree
of emotional and
psychological nourishment.
Academically and
educationally, I still
feel that we have
a long way to go,
because so many more
things we have to do.
And there are
constraints of HR there,
like our location, why
that's far from the city.
So there may be
concerns outside,
and we'll grapple with that.
But nothing stops us
from making Parivaar
a very, very high degree of
emotionally nourishing place.
So that has been the
case, right from day
one when we were very,
very low on resources.
So it's about the environment.
So we have our own
[INAUDIBLE], working staff who
actually stay on the campus.
I have always lived
with the kids.
That has been my family.
So when I started,
I also decided
that I will not have any
other thing in my life.
So you know that
simplified my life.
So as a result, I
never got married even.
And my parents were
at some other place
so didn't have much of a social
obligation outside Parivaar.
So it was like this.
So this has been my
family And for a tier
of the resident people
who live at Parivaar
and call it their family.
And in addition, we have our
own 90 more daytime staff
for our daytime roles.
It could be teaching,
tutoring, all these things.
So lots of things.
You could say on fun and
joy and happiness quotient
enhancements.
So all the things
you can imagine
which happen in a household--
celebrations, festivities,
excursions, carnivals,
culturally--
a huge amount of cultural
events, et cetera.
Infrastructure-wise, right
from a rented building,
then I, for the first
time, took to [INAUDIBLE].
Now it became our own,
nearly 20 acres of land
now and in two campuses.
We have an immediate campus.
One is for-- both are in
the same locality, actually,
and are adjacent to each other.
One is for the girls.
And there, primarily, we have
our women resident staff.
It's very, very
difficult, actually,
to manage a girls'
residential home.
And people would not
venture into doing that.
There are very, very few
girls' residential institutions
in India, whereas they
are the most vulnerable.
Reason is that it's
very, very difficult
to find resident women,
which you need for a girls'
residential institute.
You can get males who could
work in India on campus.
They can stay.
But usually our candidates
for having resident women
is maybe women who are
not married, et cetera.
I mean, the social
customs are maybe--
in India it's usually like
married men can go out, get
some other place,
and stay at resident
or in overnight hall, but
very hard to find women.
So that has always
been a constant.
But right from the
beginning, I was
dissuaded from actually
working and starting
the girls' residentialship.
Only women's social
entrepreneurs
have done that mostly in India.
But I was very, very sure,
right from the beginning that
we'll have both girls'
institution as well as boys'.
And we had a common residential
institution for at least
first six, seven years.
And after that only
we were in a position
to have different institutions.
Actually, having
common is, in fact,
not-- some guidelines are
also there in the government,
that you are not
allowed to do that.
But somehow, we managed
to see that period.
So these are some very wonderful
cases-- particularly these
three, because these
three, after graduation,
are also working at Parivaar.
They chose to actually
give back for-- at least
for the next three,
four years at Parivaar.
So they are in very key roles.
Firoz he was like-- 10
years back you can see.
And now he's in an important
position in our finance
accounting department.
Suman now is looking after child
admissions administrative role.
Ten years back, he, himself,
was a-- 11 years back
got admitted to Parivaar.
And Shubham, again, from a very
vulnerable, traffic-prone area.
His sisters were
also-- well, you
could say victims
of trafficking.
And from there, he was-- all
the siblings were admitted.
He's now a science teacher
in higher grades, mathematics
and in the sciences.
So this kind of a
spirit of-- actually
there are many children who
are-- since they've come out
of this system only, and
they carry this vision
and philosophy of Parivaar.
So I am very-- this
was my dream, actually,
that the future
leaders of Parivaar
should include in a major
way the children who
have come through Parivaar.
That was the legacy
I wanted to leave.
So it's actually turning
out in that manner only.
Now, in tribal areas
also we outreached
and created a field network.
In and around Kolkata,
our institution
has become well known so
cases on their own come to us.
But there are so many areas
which are almost cut off
from the rest of the country.
These are Naxal-affected
areas, and even police
doesn't enter into these areas.
So here, we actually outreach
created field network
through local-- holding
community meetings.
I remember in one Naxal
tribal area in 2007
when during late evening
when nobody ventures
because there are these mines.
It's got mines, which are
placed and a bomb blast,
kids get blasted there.
So but still, we ventured there.
And like in any random
interior village,
I then brought-- the village
elders I brought to Parivaar.
I said they'd be our
guest for, say, one week.
And in every village, there are
some respected village elders.
They are also from
the same community,
but they are kind of opinion
leaders in that area.
So we just brought them.
And they stayed at
Parivaar and then went back
and spread the word.
So in areas where
nobody knew us,
these kind of
approaches also we took.
And then after that, all these
relatives of the children
became our local volunteers.
They are our field workers.
We don't have recruited
staff for all that.
All these relatives of the
children from far-flung area,
they themselves are
a contact person.
They do, then, the
primary referencing
of more children in that
region, and all the liaisoning
part with the area.
These are two main
tribes-- [INAUDIBLE]
and [INAUDIBLE] We do a
lot of other things here.
Like around 3,000 other
children's education,
we support through
various field groups which
we have created in this field.
And so this, Parivaar,
its main aspect
is the residential instrument,
a lot of other ancillary support
activity does.
So 3,000 children's
education, we
do a food stock scheme,
some 600, 700 households
are covered.
And around 15,000,
20,000 kilograms
of [INAUDIBLE] every month
are fed into interior areas.
These are starvation areas.
And there are times when
there is a family in condition
of starvation.
Deaths even happen
in many such areas.
So all this, also, we do.
Since we are integrated
into those field areas.
So these commitments,
also, we have to fulfill.
Like here, it's [INAUDIBLE]
to additional 2,600 boys
and all outside Parivaar
from this local area.
Monthly food stock scheme--
this is for elderly.
And there are other
families in the tribal area.
But elderly are
uncared for women
who are begging on the
streets, like that, with no one
to take care of.
So particularly, elderly uncared
women-- medical support, food
stock support, and in
general Parivaar acts
as a guardian of the
entire local area
in case of any exigency.
So ours is the
door they'll knock
for any kind of
exigency support.
Future-- this is how
we will be scaling.
We may start a
similar institution
in the next few
years, and possibly
in Jharkhand, Madhya
Pradesh, or Chhattisgarh.
These are also on our radar.
But at the same
location, itself,
we are scaling
three or four times.
We have land, et cetera,
for 3,000, 4,000 children.
So that will happen
at our area itself,
present area with Bengal near
Kolkata, but at the same time
in some other states where
we have a local village base.
So finally speaking, Parivaar--
a continuous fest of joy
and learning.
This is what Parivaar is.
And the central
government, particularly,
has recognized our work--
government of India.
And they've inducted me into
also-- three-fourths in point--
the ministerial communities.
Like I am on the
HRD's ministry, which
is the education
ministry in India's apex
advisory body for developing
the education policy.
Similarly, in Ministry of Women
and Child, it's advisory board.
In Ministry of
Finance, the aspect
of finance ministry which deals
with NGOs in general, like they
are taxation and regulations
which should guide the NGO
sector, So all on that also.
So it's like this--
a few years back
Parivaar was elected
the best child welfare
institution in
the entire country
by the president of India.
Now, these are just
a few tables, OPEX,
and per child it comes to
around in Indian rupees
be close to 440 rupees
annually per child,
which is around US $650
US for a resident child.
And you can see that nearly
half of it-- at least 40% to 45%
is the funding component itself.
So it's like this.
And our OPEX it's around
Indian rupee crore,
which now the exchange
rates have gone up already.
So now it's around
US $800,000 a year.
It was $1 million, but due to
the exchange rate in dollar
it comes to $800,000 USD.
And we have to do a lot
of infrastructure buildup.
So around half a million
dollars each year,
we expend on infrastructure
buildup for scaling
up, for creating the residential
work, and all infrastructure
facility for the kids.
So nearly $1.5 million
we raise, and primarily,
as I said, through individuals.
It's like this.
So this is-- I stop here, and
I can take some questions now.
We have, I think, 15 minutes.
Yeah, so other
than that, I also,
now, work a lot on the network
level of particularly young
social entrepreneurs.
So I also convened, along
with some other friends.
We have a very significant
philanthropic platform
called Caring Friends.
So it has more than 25 very good
grassroots organizations there.
So I do a lot of support and,
actually, access to funding,
et cetera, for those
organizations as well.
And mentoring young social
entrepreneurs, particularly
those who have left some
kind of [INAUDIBLE] careers
and are venturing into
this, because in India, it's
still a very, very--
it's insecure and full
of uncertainty.
It's perceived as
that, actually.
So just to give them
a feeling that we
are with you and ensuring a
sense of security, etc cetera.
I mean, initially
it's particular
to such social entrepreneurs.
And so a number of such
organizations here,
hand-holding.
So we have these caring,
friendly individuals here with
us, along with Parivaar's.
Yeah, we can-- yeah.
[APPLAUSE]
FEMALE SPEAKER: Thanks a
lot for coming, Vinayak.
This was very inspirational.
VINAYAK LOHANI: Thank you.
FEMALE SPEAKER: I have a
question around-- so obviously,
you have had the privilege
to go to an IIT, an IIM,
and have that type of education.
And because of that--
or I'd rather say,
despite of that-- you
chose to do something that
was coming from your heart.
And you really
followed that calling.
What are you doing
with these children?
What type of education
are you providing them
to do the same that you did?
And you mentioned
a couple of cases,
where kids are helping
out at the school
after they're graduating,
or once they're old enough.
But how do you
make sure that they
have that sense of
gratitude and give back
to where they came from, rather
than aspire for great careers
in, let's say, the
US or anywhere else.
VINAYAK LOHANI: There's
nothing wrong with aspiring--
FEMALE SPEAKER: There's
nothing wrong with it.
I mean, we would welcome them.
VINAYAK LOHANI: My work is
supported by such people, who
aspired for their careers.
So I would be the last person
to say anything against that.
And here, as far as kids
at Parivaar are concerned,
it's like-- you know in
the environment, gratitude
I always feel is the most
basic human sentiment.
Every human being
should have that.
I am very, very grateful
to Parivaar children
that I got an opportunity to--
so it's a common sentiment
that everyone should have.
But it can't be forced
down your throat.
So we are giving opportunities
through that first, let
them manifest their potential.
And I am sure that
with the kind of values
which the environment
at Parivaar had,
naturally it will
have its effect.
But we don't-- like as far
as this value of education is
concerned, I don't believe in a
moral science kind of classroom
kind of thing.
I always think that--
Swami Vivekananda once
said that if you want
to ever teach anyone
to be good, if you want
to reform John Doe,
live with John Doe.
And if you have any of the
fire of purity, he'll catch it.
So it's like this.
It's about living with-- living
and through your own life.
I think children are quick
learners of how elders
are behaving, etc cetera,
however so you may philosophize
or [INAUDIBLE].
So this is like first
giving them chance,
and I'm sure that those
things happen, naturally.
MALE SPEAKER: What can
we Googlers and experts
do to help social
enterprises in India?
VINAYAK LOHANI:
The first thing is
about engaging with social
enterprises, greater
degree of engagement.
First to ensure
[INAUDIBLE] experience
of visiting organizations.
And in a very remote way, it
may be difficult, not so easy.
Like I am very often
asked this question,
that we do not know how the--
if we make a donation, how
it will get utilized.
Actually, it's not
that difficult.
It's actually kind of a
lazy way of engagement,
because of which these
kind of things come.
For example, there are direct
grass-root organizations.
People generally do
through intermediaries,
or through funding
agency, and then they
are extending support.
So one doesn't know.
But directly there
are organizations.
There are-- like
our friends here,
these two are also
engaging with a number
of-- [INAUDIBLE] is a Googler.
So they are engaging
directly, visiting
a number of organizations
in India when they go back.
So actually, through
direct engagement,
you get a much better exposure.
You get ideas of how to help.
It could be at the
level of ideas.
He has done, for example, a
lot for many organizations
while being at the US and
also when he was in India.
So it's like one has to
engage, first come and touch,
and that needs some
kind of an effort.
You have to get out of your
comfort zone for doing that.
MALE SPEAKER: Thanks
for stopping in today.
VINAYAK LOHANI: Yeah, thank you.
MALE SPEAKER: And it's
exciting to see what you said.
I had two questions.
The first one is-- I think
you partly answered that.
Based on what you
presented, it looks
like there is a need for
some kind of a venture,
that there is a need for some
kind of funding as you scale up
your operations.
And secondly, you also
mentioned that people over here
can actually engage
more in a real sense.
What are some
other things that--
besides these two, what are
some of the immediate needs that
are on the top of your mind?
That's one question.
And the second question,
which is sort of unrelated,
is how is the
government helping?
Are you getting
help, positive help?
Thank you.
VINAYAK LOHANI: So I'll just
take the second part first.
The government--
financial funding support
from government in India
happens in a different way.
Government has a number
of social welfare schemes.
And if we run those
schemes directly
under those parameters, in the
sense that you are kind of-- I
would use the analogy of
being a subcontractor, so
a subcontractor of
government schemes.
If you run, then you
get those kind of funds.
But in programs or
organizations or initiatives
which have been designed, which
are not commissioned projects
but are designed by some
entrepreneurs or founder
and under your own design
parameter you want to do,
then you don't have access
to those government funds.
And even if you have, there is a
huge amount of loss of autonomy
by taking government
funds in India.
And government in
India is also--
we have to understand
that there is
a state government
in each state,
and it's government of India.
And usually, the
social way is you
have to deal with the state
government, local state
government, through channels
of local bureaucracy,
local, say, panchayat system.
There's a huge amount of
political interference there.
So that's not--
when I started, I
didn't think that
was an answer to go
and building your organization.
You lose control.
But when you are in a
position of strength,
then you can really
start dealing a bit more
with the government.
So now we are like-- some
kind of access we have.
For example, there
is a provision
of MPLAD for a member of
Parliament's local area
development.
So that doesn't come through
the ministerial departments,
purely discretionary of
the member of Parliament.
So a good member of
Parliament, there are a few,
like-- I mean, particularly
in the Rajya Sabha, which is
the House of Elders in India.
And there are
president-nominated MPs there.
So those are people who are
not from the political system.
I mean, [INAUDIBLE]
was in their own field.
So a few of them have
actually supported us.
So there is also
government funding,
where it doesn't come through
the conventional route.
So about that, it's
a choice one has
to make about loss of
autonomy and access to funds.
Then about this, yeah.
Your first part,
Parivaar is scaling up.
So financial support would need
for that will always remain.
But there are so many
other ways of engaging.
Like from the US itself,
many of our supporters--
for example, who have a
little bit more grown up kids.
So we have a kid's exchange
program, for example.
Not exchange-- their
kids, only come
and staying for a
few weeks, and it's
like-- living and sharing with.
I don't use the
volunteering for that,
but just living and sharing.
So a lot of cross-cultural
learning for both our kids
as well as those
who are visiting.
That has been a very
successful thing at our end.
So many diverse fields
of engagement are there.
And as I said,
that I-- today I am
representing not just in my
own work but sector as a whole.
There are so many
other good initiatives.
But right now, there is a
very, very divested thing,
you know, famine in Marathwada
region in Maharashtra
where 10 farmers each day
are committing suicide.
I am also urging most
of my supporters,
actually, to extend
support there.
So one of our [INAUDIBLE]
mentored by us,
actually, is actually
doing a lot there.
So many situations
are there when caring.
So I think you should
have an engagement
with the whole ecosystem
of organizations,
in fact, all the
various domains.
It's just like how
in a stock market,
you follow a number
of stocks, OK?
Their positions and their
stories change over time.
So similarly, as
for the engagement
in social sector in
India is concerned,
I think that should be the way.
Yeah, yeah.
MALE SPEAKER: Can we
have flyers in case
we want to get involved.
VINAYAK LOHANI: Yeah, this whole
Caring Friend network, also we
have so far 25 organizations--
25 best organizations in India,
we have literature here today.
FEMALE SPEAKER: So I
have two questions.
One is, when-- you took a path
that was off the beaten track,
right?
What was the reaction
of your parents?
And then secondly,
as you were growing,
did politicians,
or local police,
or anybody get in the way?
VINAYAK LOHANI: Yeah.
So now, first thing was that
I did not belong to Kolkata.
In fact, I did not
know anyone in Kolkata.
And I started there.
So I had to learn
the local language,
integrated myself with the
local culture, all that.
And I had come to Kolkata
only for doing my [INAUDIBLE],
but I got caught up in such
a company of people who were
related to these kind of thing.
So I used to visit organizations
and volunteer, and all that.
So that got me going.
Otherwise, maybe
that would-- there
are so many things against
me, odds are against me there
in that area.
But the momentum and the mind
inspiration got built up there.
So at that time, I never
discussed this with my family.
I never gave them a chance
to register their views.
So I never got to
know of their views,
because I never went back
home for many years, actually.
And they-- like some
of my little sister,
or other relative used to come.
So slowly, my-- my mother
was actually very supportive.
My father, being a
more practical person,
he was worried.
And he didn't trust me enough.
He thought that I
am a-- I mean, he
had the image of
an immature kid.
So he thought that I'll
mess up everything.
But in course of
time there, I think,
became very good friends.
So I have their blessings.
MALE SPEAKER: And
all of us wish really
best for you and Parivaar.
VINAYAK LOHANI: Thank you.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]